my plan B if the gym didn't work I would  strip at night and I would drive Uber I  knew if I drove 12 hours a day I could  make like 80 90 grand a year if I just  did that and then at night in four or  five hours I could probably pull another  150 in I could make 250 000 a year just  stripping and driving Uber maybe even  more once I got the first level of  skills so I learned how to sell I  realized that my base level opportunity  Rose because then I was like I could  just sell cars and make 400 000 a year  and keep my clothes on so that became my  new Baseline once I knew how to Market  and sell then my new Baseline became I  flew out and would do the turnkey sales  system when I did that on my own no  employees I'd make 100 a month and so  that became my new Baseline